Now that we've set up our "Hello World" project,
we should be able to see our IntelliJ environment,
which is this split screen.
On the left we have our project layout,
that shows our main project folder named "Hello world! "
Let's expand this folder.
SRC is short for source and that refers to the source code,our main code of our program.
Let's expand this.
Inside here you might recognize
our base package name and inside that is something called Main.
Main is something called the class and you'll learn
more about classes when we talk about objects later.
But for now know that all the code and functions you write will be inside classes.
Main is what we want to pay attention to.
And in fact, on the right side of our screen is all the code contained in
our main class and there's this main function that I mentioned before.
Whenever you write a program,
your computer needs to know where to start running your code
and by default it will always start at this main function.
Inside this function is where you place all the lines of code you want to execute.
Like if you want to print out a line of text,
you'll have to call the print line function inside this main function.
For this program, we want to execute a line of code that prints out, "Hello world! "
We can do that just by writing a simple print line statement here.
We'll start by saying system and you
can see that just when I type in the starting letters for system,
IntelliJ helps me by suggesting the code that I'm writing.
Then, I can write.out and.println,
with IntelliJ helping me every step of the way.
Then inside these parentheses,
I'll write the string that I want to print out.
That's just "Hello World!"
Let's save this by pressing command S or save all.
We have one more thing to check before we run this program.
Let's click on this run tab and go down to edit configurations.
Then this window pops up and you should see four filled in fields.
The first, is our main class that we want to run,
which is, com.company main. This is correct.
Next is our working directory,
which is just where our project has been saved.
Then we have the class-path of our module and
this just specifies the project folder that our main class is in.
And that's our project, "Hello world! "
IntelliJ should automatically select this for you but if it doesn't,
just use this drop down menu to find it.
Then, it has a Java run-time environment
and this should say that we're using version 1.8,
which is the version of Java that I downloaded.
This all looks good and usually this information is filled in automatically.
But it's always a good idea to double check,
so we don't have to change anything here.
I'll just click, okay and this will exit back to our program.
We can run this in two ways, by clicking,
run main or by clicking this run button at
the top right of our program and I'll use this.
After we press run,
we can see that a third window pops up at the bottom of our screen.
This is called our console and this is where all of our print statements will print out.
Running this program we see the expected print output.
And whenever we write system.out.println our main method,
the lines will print out in our console,
in the order that they're called in our main function.
You may have noticed that we only had to run our code and that's
because IntelliJ automatically compiles our code before we run it.
This makes it easier to change code too.
I can go into my code and change this to "Hello Java! "
and then I'll save this again and press run.
In our console window we see our updated text,
" Hello Java! "
IntelliJ is really useful.
It does; text highlighting,
automatic code completion and let's you change and run code really quickly and easily.
Congrats on completing your first hello world program in IntelliJ.
I'd recommend adding onto this program with a few lines of code of your own.
Maybe try adding two numbers and printing out
that value or displaying any message of your own.
That's the best way to get familiar with IntelliJ
and comfortable writing programs on your own computer.